هذا التمييز المدقع بين اليهود
يهود فرنسا الاجانب نيابة عن
الفكاهة تقودني لأتحدث إليكم عن دراما
اثنان من كبار المفكرين الألمان في القرن العشرين
يهود القرن الأجانب مثل دي ريزي
مور اثنين من المثقفين
ألقى ظهور النازية على
طرق المنفى هذه م أرندت
و val بواسطة بنيامين
في المنزل لجأ إلى فرنسا و
وصل باريس عام 1933
في مايو 1944 تم اعتقالها مع
آلاف النساء في مخيم غورس غورس
مقطع لفظي مضحك مثل البكاء
من لا يخرج من حلقه فاكتب له
راجان
تمكن الفيلسوف الشاب من الهروب
ينضم إلى مونتوبان ثم مرسيليا حيث هي
يحصل بفضل المراكز الأمريكية في
انقاذ تأشيرة دخول للبرتغال حيث هي
ستنجح في الشروع في الولايات
توحد في مايو 1941 بتأشيرة دخول
هو قانوني
سوف تحصل أرنت على الجنسية
أمريكي وسيصبح عظيما
فيلسوف
ولديها فكرة عمل
تميز تركت لنا
أصول الشمولية
تركت لنا رجل الثلج في القدس
تركت لنا أزمة
حضاره
غادرنا
يوميات التفكير
للأسف
لم يكن لدى فالتر بينيامين نفس الشيء
حظ
في يونيو 1940 وسمح لهم بذلك
حسابات الورنيش ch بالقرب من nevers حيث
هذا صحيح بفضل المثقفين
أصدقاء
هرب بنيامين إلى جنوب فرنسا
يصل إلى مرسيليا ويكون الأول
محاولة مؤسفة لمغادرة
فرنسا نعرف الاختباء في سفينة شحن
25 سبتمبر 1940
مع مجموعة صغيرة بقيادة
ناشط ضرائب شيوعي
عبر بنيامين الحدود الفرنسية
الأسبانية
بعد مشي مرهق 9 ساعات
لقد وصل إلى عتبة داركم في كاتالونيا
تقدم لرجال الشرطة الاسبانية مع
تأشيرة الولايات المتحدة
لكن للأسف تأشيرة العبور الخاصة به
غير صالح
يسمح له بقضاء الليل في الميناء
حسنًا ، نحن ننتظر تسليمنا إلى الجستابو
غدا
بينيامين متعب ويائس
الانتحار ليلة 26 إلى 27 سبتمبر
الساعة 8 مساءً يدخل بنيامين عامل مركب كبير في
الثقافة والثقافة الفرنسية
الألمانية وترجمته proust لديه
أحب باريس قال باريس هو أ
مكتبة عبرت من قبل المشهد
سيكون بعد وفاته هذا العمل الفريد
من نوعه
بعنوان عاصمة باريس في القرن التاسع عشر
إنه طريق طويل
بين المنشور الذي يزرع
كراهية الذات والآخرين
وغيرها من الشخصيات التي تحمل
تصل قيم مجتمعنا
إنسانية